it's so good to meet you how are you
doing love hon bindi bindi taking a
break from rehearsing for tonight's
Dancing with the Stars to visit kids at
Children's Hospital Los Angeles with her
mom Terry it's super personal but it's
so beautiful a few people say I wish I
bought an animal so next time I come
back hop to see if I can bring him out
um or we watch your dance this Monday oh
good this is my halloween costume for
the day Pocky this is what I normally
wear at home but during our life I'm a
ranger for the day I'm dressed as the
mother of a ranger last weekend marked
bindis first-ever Halloween celebration
I get scared so easily that I think I'll
just be having my cup of tea maybe
playing a bit of Monopoly she's a wild
one but I'll try to keep her into
control yeah to be here in the States
for Halloween has been so much fun
I love the even the hospital celebrates
Halloween in such a huge way tonight
bindi will honor Grace Kelly for icon
week on Dancing with the Stars this
dance is gonna be exciting we're doing
the foxtrot this week and yeah it's been
it's been a big week every single week
there are different challenges and
different things that you have to learn
so it'll be fun we'll see what happens
hopefully all goes well